لاخان كالي هو طفل في التاسعه من العمر
مصاب بشلل دماغي وهو اصم وابكم يقضي يومه
مقيدا ليل نهار بسلسله مشدوده الى عمود
تستند اليه محطه حافلات الى محطه الحافله
تلك يصل هو وجدته يوميا فتقي ثم تسعى وراء
رزقها على ان تعود اليه لاحقا وتقول انه
كان عليها ربطه فلم يكن لديها اي خيار اخر
وتقول جدته انها ان لم تربطه فانه سيضيع
في الزحام وقد يذهب بعيدا ولانه لا يستطيع
سماع منبهات السيارات فمن المرجح ان يقتل
كما انها لا تستطيع تركه في البيت لانه
ببساطه هذا هو المكان الذي تعيش فيه
الرصيف وهي ليست لوحدها على هذه الحال
فالكثيرون من الفقراء ينامون وياكلون هنا
واما الجده سكوبي فجميع ممتلكاتها موجوده
بحقيبتي فقط سكوبا هي الراعيه الوحيده
للطفل لاخان بعد ان توفي والده وبعد ان
هجرت والدته
والعائله وتقول الجده انه لا يوجد احد
يساعدها بمن فيهم المسؤولون الذين يمرون
من هذا الطريق كل يوم والشهر الماضي ظهرت
هذه الصور في احدى الصحف المحليه وقامت
الشرطه باخذ لخا الى مركز عا
صحيه تقول مينا ماثو من المؤسسه انها
عندما راته كان يحتاج لرعايه ومنزل فاخذته
لماوى ترعاه الحكومه حيث لم يسمح لنا
بالتصوير والصبي ليس وحده فقصته هي قصه
الكثير من الاطفال في جميع انحاء مومبي من
ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه الذين لا يحصلون
على اي مساعده او اي شكل من اشكال الرعايه
الاجتماعيه والحياتيه من ضمنهم التقينا
بعبد الرزاق البالغ من العمر 12 سنه في
احد الاحياء الفقيره
فيفاري وهو يعاني من حاله متقدمه من الشلل
الدماغي عندما تذهب والدته الى عملها
تحبسه في البيت وتقول الدكتوره شابنام
رانجو ان تلبيه احتياجات المعوقين ليست من
اولويات الحكومه ففي مدينه يعيش فيها نحو
20 مليون شخص يكون الاطفال مثل عبد الرزاق
ولاخان لا مرئيين ولا احد يهتم بهم تقريبا
وتقول جده لاخان انها تفتقده ولكن اذا
ماتت يوما ما فعلى الاقل سيكون لديه سقف
فوق راسه وهذا اكثر ما تستطيع توفيره على
هذا الرسيف